braxton garrett gets the ball it's his
fourth start and fifth game of 2021 last
time we saw him was over the weekend in
philadelphia
covering his last 13 games that was a
little bit high but they get the call on
the swing bill miller the crew chief at
first
brings him up
and here is fernando and his great
number sitting at 290.
here's a drive to deep left field back
goes princeton at the wall who watch it
fly out of here fernando tatis jr
home run number 30 of the year fernando
and the padres strike first on top one
to nothing
ryan is on the bound for the padres 21
year old making his 12th start it's been
13 days since his last time remember he
was uh helped off the field because of
that ankle injury manny machado and jazz
having a good time
jazz trying his best to distract
manhattan they off pitch
and that is strike three got him at the
knees and it was a strike call rojas
doesn't like it but it was a strike and
that's out number one
two and two
swinging to miss and braxton garrett has
a couple of strikeouts
there's a called strike three
a couple of k's in the second for
braxton garrett
strike three and weathers takes very
quick care of it second strike out of
the night for ryan
2-2
swing and a miss and back-to-back case
for ryan weathers three and all two down
here in the second inning
here's ryan weathers who bats
right-handed swings in the first pitch
guys want to deep center field marta
going back looking up gonna go
first home run in the big leagues for
ryan weathers and the third straight
game that a padre pitcher gets a hit
weathers doubles the lead it's two to
nothing here in the third
into center field it's a hit parade for
these pitchers today
[Applause]
on the ground towards shortstop could be
two to second for one on to first it is
two
a six four three dp
and this one is driven to left but right
at fam who makes the catch
against weathers out of the jam
ground ball to short rojas takes it
himself and on the first to double play
austin is the older brother and he looks
at strike three
on one and two a swing and a miss
number four for ryan weathers and one
out at the bottom of the fourth inning
a wide open left side here's the one and
two he took a half swing at it missed it
balls dropped by alfaro alfaro throws a
bloop to first base here's the pitch
swing and a miss struck him out
a one two three fifth and seven
strikeouts for braxton garrett
off the il weathers four shutout frames
couple of hits he walked three hit a
batter struck out four and threw 73
pitches
[Applause]
runs it in and he strikes out martay
azuz aguilar two outs
so again a 2-2 pitch
and this one to third
machado on the line high throw
it's wide of the first base bag aguilar
is safe
he and profar collide a little bit both
look to be all right rojas scores the
run and it's now two to one
respectively the pitch over strike three
calls tatis puts his hands on his hips
turns and looks at doug eddings
and uh he's having a conversation with
endings
doug eddings telling chase tingler that
that's it
one warning
i don't want to hear any more of it
and i
wonder mere moment after the warning if
jace tingler has anything to say about
that
cut on and missed nola picks it up fires
to first
and completes the strikeout two away
one-two pitch
and i think he went yeah he did strikes
out that's the first one two three
inning for padres pitching
we head to the seventh patrice have a
2-1 lead
and another one as well and this might
do it jayce tingler is coming out he has
just about had it
but i think he's going to do a little
bit of protecting kim and a little bit
of pleading his case
and doug eddings has been at least in
the last couple of innings maybe all day
around the zone but the last two innings
in particular with the padres
up and down
and the up and the down is what the
manager can see from the duggar well
there's no doubt about it but you've got
to remember that you know there's been a
little bit of chirping that's going on
so there's some back and forth between
the padres players and what's going on
at home plate doug ennis i mean that's
just it's simple facts and i think to
your point this game has gone a little
old school
here's your opportunity
base has loaded one out aguilar to the
plate
two and two that's in the center field
that's a base hit and comes sierra rojas
around third he is gonna score the
marlins get two and take the lead
42nd game for floro hosmer a fly ball
out to left center field long way back
sierra marte both there leaping and who
caught it starlight marta got it right
in front of the wall
what a play
fantastic catch right in front of the
defender
you see this in football more than
baseball i think that he caught that
underneath prince and watch princeton
over the top of his glove he misses it
and marte's on the back side
oh really wow one on one
no it's inside yeah
inside corner
yeah stick it to him go ahead really
yeah you're done oh skip schumacher just
got tossed all right
and he's going to come out and say some
stuff now
get your money's worth skip
get your money's worth
[Applause]
[Music]
ground ball
pagan's got it he will take it himself
to the bag and that'll end the inning
works his way around back-to-back base
hits to begin the inning we're headed
for the ninth padres trailing three to
two
[Music]
swinging a miss for strike three
back to the slider for route number one
yeah that's what you're really hoping
for and he put it in a great spot
delivers and a ground ball
easton diaz flips to miggy throw to
first is not in time ball gets away from
aguilar and miggy down in a heap at
second base
and what rojas is asking for is if
grisham
slid in a little bit too hard at second
base and we'll see don mattingly is
going to go out maybe get an explanation
there and again that rule is you've got
to be able to keep control of the
of the second base bag
and if you don't as that runner going
into second base if you don't and
collide with the fielder it's an
automatic double play and the marlins
are going to take a look at it
yeah this is going to be a spectacular
double play if they finished it a
backhand flip from isaan to rojas who
was in stride
grisham didn't slide in fact
a left
shoulder to the hip of rojas who was
trying to finish off this double play
[Music]
so the question you have to ask is there
some obligation on the runners part to
get down
it looked as though grisham was thinking
about it maybe caught in between we've
got our answer
and they've got it that's an automatic
double play
and now jase tingler wants an
explanation
but
because grisham didn't do his best to
get down and not interfere
with rojas
well he basically induces the double
play and i can't believe i'm saying it
but it's a marlins win
thank you that's what i was waiting for
that's what we want to know marlon's
fans there you go
what a night what a win